yeah he was uh like the third to
announce uh this detection of
some sort of an object at the center of
the milky way galaxy but now we are
talking about external galaxies
with a galactic astronomer meaning that
he is one of the best in the whole
galaxy and it's my friend adam reese
where are you joining us from today adam
i'm in baltimore maryland ah beautiful
baltimore the crab cake capital of the
world
i remember visiting there when i was a
nine-year-old visiting baltimore for the
first time and seeing all these bail
ponds places and i remember one adam and
it said
their logo their motto was we get your
feet back on the streets and i just
thought that was so sweet you know i
thought it was wonderful
so it's great to see you again we have
many many people watching online we have
questions coming in rapidly
and we'll let the chat room kind of fill
in and uh first of all i just want to
say uh it's great to have you back on
the show you're a three-time guest now
and uh you've been so generous in the
time that we since we talked last uh
been a lot of developments in your
universe and then cosmology as a whole
and we want to talk about all that and
take questions from the audience because
i have the brightest audience in the
known universe
uh and they're just champing you know
chomping or champ they're champing or
chomping at the bit to talk to you about
these new results uh so first of all um
i want to begin by maybe just getting
from you
uh what what has been achieved is so
spectacular i'm teaching cosmology this
quarter and i want to get your input on
some of this but i always you know i
have to brag and name drop and actually
this is my office hours now so physics
162 students
you're being monitored in the chat room
uh you have to ask a question and you
won't pass the clock just kidding um but
here's your chance to talk to a renowned
astronomer um
[Laughter]
stop the champ yeah um
so we talked a lot this year just in the
last couple of months about the
mysterious universe of things like uh of
things like uh supernovae how do i ask
you first so i brought in this this year
adam and then i'll let you talk because
i'm sorry i'm just so excited but this
year i decided to do something new in
cosmology to do lab demonstrations can
you imagine lab demos in a cosmology
class um so i brought in like bunsen
burners and black bodies and doppler
shift things but now i brought in
actually a supernova so i have a i have
a supernova core collapse which i'll
i'll send you because your chap your
chapter one in in my most recent book uh
hoberman sphere right oh that's right
yeah very good uh so we could do a
demonstration of supernova what
fascinates you the most about these
objects how well do we know what they
are are they really standard candles
that i preach to my students are they
not standards
right so
um just to be clear there's two two
basic types of supernova the kind in
your hand is the core collapse and those
are when massive stars collapse uh and
then rebound and explode and the kind
that we use for cosmology is a different
type
their thermonuclear supernovae what we
call type 1a which is kind of a uh
taxonomy name but what we really mean is
a white dwarf that approaches the
chandrasekhar limit which is as we know
a sacred limit of a physics limit
that uh 1.4 times the mass of the sun
that electron pressure cannot hold up
the star and you get runaway
thermonuclear explosion and so when you
ask are they good standard candles you
know the chandra state car limit gives
us a reason to believe that they ought
to be pretty good standard candles in
fact you know there is nothing else i'm
aware of at that kind of scale
where we get a nice physics limit like
that that that gives you a reason to
believe that they would all blow up at
the same luminosity now there are small
variations and with those we can
empirically calibrate and so that's what
we do and then we see these very far
away
and they're as bright as 5 billion solar
luminosities and so we can see them very
far away and gauge the expansion rate of
the universe
and before that uh the gold standard was
uh or cepheid variables and i've always
you know been a little confused how do
we
you know levitt
and hubble and slifer to whatever extent
he was involved in that how did they
calibrate so accurately the period
luminosity relationship i mean it seemed
like they had they didn't even know
about what the nucleus was back then in
the 19s how could they possibly know
with confidence that cepheids were these
nuclear processes when they didn't know
anything about nuclear physics
right so part of the answer is they
didn't calibrate them very well they
calibrated them very poorly and so the
consequence was uh
misgating distances in the universe by a
pretty dramatic amount by
uh close to an order of magnitude um and
so that has been the journey we've been
on for a hundred years i would say you
know when henrietta levitt saw
cepheid variables in the small
magellanic cloud right she recognized
well they are all equidistant to us and
so the fact that their
period correlates so strongly with their
brightness told you that they were
excellent standard candles but this
quest to figure out exactly what their
luminosity is and then therefore be able
to use them to gauge distances and the
expansion rate the hubble constant
that's been the hard part that's what's
taken us i'm gonna say a hundred years
and we'll go on
into the future uh but that's really
what the news is is that we think now
we've calibrated them very well
how much would you give in terms of
children or teeth that you were kind
enough to offer to pull one of my teeth
so that we could make this part
how much would you give for a supernova
of any kind uh at a red shift of three
or two or something like that is that
even in the realm of possibilities and
if it were would it just nail this
forever to have such a high redshift you
know calibrated standard candle or am i
just wishfully thinking
um yeah actually what's interesting is
to measure what we've been talking about
most recently the hubble constant we
actually don't want to go to
particularly high redshift we want to
make extremely precise measurements all
in the local universe so the action here
is all at redshift less than 0.1 it's
all you know 100 million
light years or hundreds of millions of
light years because we want to be able
to compare to how the universe looked
early on in your you know your belly
wick the cosmic ray background and
compared to what uh the cosmic ray
background plus the standard model
predicts the expansion rate should be
today
right and that's where the tension will
come in and we'll get into that tension
and as i've said we need to have a
a a cosmologist a friendly therapist for
the field and i want to get into your
favorite non
you know
supernova related tension we'll get to
that there's a lot of tensions coming up
and as your fellow nobel laureate
stephen weinberg once said physics
thrives on crises but he said luckily
there aren't that many crises uh i think
that
that's really right
that is something i certainly would want
people to understand is when they hear
us talk about crises intentions uh they
might hear it like it's a bad thing and
to us this is the only way we move
forward is to find places where our
understanding breaks down and so this
has been the path forever of science is
we have a model you know all models are
useful but none are correct and we apply
that model and it breaks somewhere and
that allows us to learn more yeah i
think that's so exciting and there's a
surface of these uh of these crises uh
question that i got during this class at
least i think it was a question i was
talking about the uh the fundamental
parameter of interest in cosmology of
course the
hubble constant that you're so expert in
is uh is has been called the most
important number in cosmology then after
that sandedge and others called the
deceleration parameter uh which you uh
have
more than your fair share of experience
because you measured it was negative for
the first time with your collaborator uh
and past guest on the podcast i've had
brian schmidt on since we last chatted
and he's a lovely man and i do want to
talk about some of the
non-astronomically significant but still
astronomically significant in terms of
career advice that he gave to me based
on his experience with you
um and being kind of a colleague and
mentor with you
the and and the lessons that you guys
learned to improve the culture of
astronomy i know that's so important to
you you've been actually you know a
really quiet you know uh champion of
inclusivity and and and developing this
community in a way that few people knew
but you know they say the the most uh
the the the kind of most righteous
people are hidden hidden hidden
righteous and i always say i want to be
the most famous hidden righteous person
in the world but anyway we'll talk about
that later but because i think you have
extremely deep insight that hasn't been
shared maybe so much on podcasts like
this so maybe we can get into that if
you'll for indulge me but um but i want
to get back to a so a the scale factor
is this immeasurable object this entity
that kind of governs everything the
first derivative evaluated today is the
half a constant second derivative is
related to the deceleration parameter
and then one of my students stood up in
class and said what about the jerk and i
was like what did he call me what did
you say uh no i said is this about steve
martin the great
um how come nobody talks about jerk
first of all what is the cosmic jerk and
does anybody study it
yes so what we're talking about in
general is
looking at the universe expand and
quantifying that by a series of
derivatives or changes so like any
object you throw an object you could
talk about its speed and then you could
talk about its changing speed its
acceleration and you could talk about
its changing acceleration which is the
jerk and so
uh in the case of our universe uh the
universe does have a jerk and it's not
me
it's not you
but it is the transition from
accelerating to decelerating and so
uh we believe that the universe was
matter dominated in the beginning
because everything was very close
together and so attractive gravity would
dominate simply because uh the
separation between objects was small at
which point the universe would be
decelerated then as it grew in size then
uh matter was more spaced out and then
this dark energy uh which was sort of
waiting in the wings became the dominant
uh
source of gravity and the universe
became accelerating so by definition if
you change from deceleration to
acceleration you have a change in the
amount of that and so that is the jerk
that is the third derivative
and it has been measured um we measured
it i think first was supernovae in the
early 2000s using the hubble space
telescope at that point our goal was
just to see if you could see that
transition uh and you can uh it's been
measured more recently with baryon
acoustic oscillations and and other
techniques like that so if the universe
did not have a jerk then we'd be in big
trouble in our understanding that would
be an even bigger tension than the ones
we've been talking about
something to look forward to
um
and an allied kind of you know concept
that i talked to the students about in
this year's cosmology class had to do
with the um the notion of
uh of what you guys called the distance
modulus the symbol is mu if i'm correct
and that's sort of the difference
between the apparent magnitude and the
intrinsic magnitude which can be related
to the observed flux of an object which
we detect and we can classify and
quantify
and then the intrinsic has to do with
the ability to standardize these candles
and i think when we spoke in late 2020
uh with wendy friedman and others about
the hubble tension as it was back then
there were some thoughts that she had
brought up about other objects that
could be the capital m in that in the
distance modulus what has been going on
in that field because i that i believe
i'm not correct uh i'm not mistaken
rather you don't study particular you
know these different objects typical you
know red giant branch or whatever
they're called um but what's been the
most exciting or interesting
developments
in that field and how does it play into
the measurements that you and your
colleagues are releasing uh recently
um
you know to me one of the biggest
developments just in the last few years
in this whole game has been a
a new satellite gaia this european
satellite which has the means to measure
parallax which is the really the gold
standard of measuring distances you just
observe an object over the course of a
year and you watch its position change
as the earth goes around the sun and
uh just by knowing the diameter of the
earth's orbit uh and simple geometry you
can tell how far away things are um and
so this business we talked about 100
years ago henrietta levitt uh knowing
that cepheus were good standard candles
but not knowing their true luminosity
and for that matter any kind of star and
its true luminosity um gaia has really
revolutionized you know quietly in some
ways in the last couple years our
ability to calibrate the true luminosity
of these objects and so the work uh if
we get to it about what's new
i'm gonna tell you about is based on
being able to calibrate luminosities
much better with gaia
particularly the what's called the third
data release which just came out last
year
and that involves astrometry um of
course and let's see measuring the
positions of things very carefully yeah
fantastic yeah i definitely want to get
into that and i want you to um uh do one
small favor adam because we have a lot
of people watching over 100 people
watching live and asking about the one
topic that they're most interested in is
can you uh mute your laptop's vibrations
uh because they are getting a little bit
motion sick let's see if we could do
that that would be great
okay
thank you yeah perfect
um
so maya bennowitz who's a longtime
friend and supporter of the show thank
you maya she is asking the question i
think that's on everybody's mind and
maybe we will uh slowly transition to it
now is there a consensus in the
community about the hubble tension
today's result is act or this last
week's result is not specifically about
the tension it's about an exquisite
measurement that you have done which may
be if i'm not mistaken the final you
know measurement by the hubble space
telescope and that of david
of this of this type of parameter the
gold standard of get a set of galaxies
or you call them mile markers or so
forth um so first of all is there a
consensus or is that not really the case
i mean if i talked to a theorist
yesterday and she and aegis at
nyu and she was saying there's no
consensus at least from the theoretical
perspective so what's the current in the
in the astronomy so the the the news
release that we had was based on a very
large study that's taken a number of
years where we've more than doubled the
data set and as i also mentioned we've
been using gaia now to calibrate uh and
so we've gotten to one kilometer per
second per megaparsec uncertainty so
that's really the big news is to get to
you know 1.3 percent in the hubble
constant now the answer we get 73
is now five sigma higher than what you
predict the value should be based on the
migrate background and the cosmological
model so you know five sigma is pretty
high uh you know we we normally say in
science uh that we're comfortable once
we're at five sigma
of not thinking of attributing this to
just luck or you know being unfortunate
or something like that
so uh you know in terms of
being definitive i i would say that's
about as definitive as we could be
in an empirical sense or an absolute
sense then you know you could look at
other techniques other ways of measuring
and in the
late universe or the local universe
those values range from about 70 to 75
but i think a good way to summarize is
there's no really precise measurement in
the late universe that is coming in any
lower than the cosmic microwave
background so they're all
high they're at different levels high
but they're all high
and our result has the smallest
uncertainty and it's five sigma high so
i would say
it's very difficult to look at this data
and make a case that these two things
are consistent
so in that sense the tension's getting
exacerbated um and yeah i would say
you know people are in pretty wide
agreement that this is a very
significant issue
uh that from the empirical side we need
to take very seriously uh i know my
colleagues feel that way because they're
putting in uh requests for telescope
time and winning that and grants and
whatnot so you know that's our measure
of when something is serious uh but on
the theoretical side there's no
consensus on what or how to explain this
and when you make claims as you do that
this is incredibly precise is it the
most precise that hubble can do and are
there any other is there any hope to
improve things on the observational
front not the theoretical
yeah so you know our our rate limiting
step is usually how many type 1a
supernovae we can reach with hubble
reach by meaning observe with cepheid
variables or tip of the red giant branch
or myras or any kind of star
and the reality is that uh
there's only about one type 1a supernova
that appears each year that is within
that volume within that range and so
what we've just published now is 42
supernovae that are basically the last
40 years worth the basically the entire
history
over which we've been observing with
digital uh tools you know you don't want
to go back to the era of photographic
plates
so now it's a waiting game you just wait
for new ones to appear at about once a
year and you can do the math it's very
difficult to imagine ever even doubling
this data set in the lifetime of hubble
so when you say is this the best we can
do i mean i'm sure technically there'll
be you know improvements here and there
but you know the sort of big picture how
many type 1a supernovae we can we can
collect and use for this measurement you
know there's just no realistic way that
hubble that telescope is going to uh
improve on this very much
now your advisor and my uh late great
your phd advisor and my late great
friend andy friedman uh may he rest in
peace wonderful man we miss him terribly
here at ucsd um he used to tell me that
the infrared had many benefits uh that
in the infrared type 1as
according to work that you and
bob and andy and others had done
was significant and i wonder if you can
explain
what that is why that is and um and if
so if there's anything that web this you
know vaunted new instrument can it say
anything about type 1a supernovae that
could improve upon even what you've done
with hubble
right so um
when we talk about infrared versus
optical um we're talking about
how you observe the standard candle that
you're looking at whether it's a cepheid
variable or a type 1a supernova
and as uh astronomers know as you know
very well there's dust in the universe
uh and dust is very tricky stuff dust
often messes up measurements it it dims
the light of things we see
fools us into thinking they're further
away than they really are
and so we try to correct or account for
dust because it generally reddens the
light as well but another powerful
method is to observe in the near
infrared or even far infrared where you
basically see through the dust that the
dust grains tend to be small enough and
the wavelengths of light in the near
infrared are large enough that they
essentially
pass through the dust without any effect
um and so for years with hubble the the
work i've been talking about we've been
observing the cepheids in the near
infrared but not the supernovae in the
near infrared now there's been a number
of papers in recent years that have
taken our results on the cepheids and
applied supernova data in the near
infrared from from as you mentioned andy
friedman
and bob kirschner and others and they
generally get the same answer whether
we're in the optical or the near
infrared
and so
that part hasn't changed the story very
much now the james webb space telescope
is a telescope that operates exclusively
pretty much in the infrared uh it's a
cold telescope and so it will have a lot
of power to look at objects in the
infrared and it has the capability to
extend some techniques we use for
distance measurements so i think it will
certainly help uh on this overall quest
to better understand the expansion rate
of the universe um it's not
obvious it's going to give us you know a
great improvement in precision but it
might test some of the ideas people have
about some of the astrophysical objects
being somehow weird or different
very good
and i'm getting a question from
a man who goes by the name that i almost
chose for my second born child his name
is memes of destruction
not the means of the structure the memes
of destruction anyway he asked uh thank
you so much professors are there any
updates or thoughts on hawking points
now i don't know if adam is
particularly um up-to-date
okay yeah i have no updates on that
well you know hawking uh was known for
many things and sir roger penrose who
came up with this idea for hawking
points as a way to determine the after
effects of previous aeons or eons your
fellow novel laureate um he used to say
that making a bat with steven
was the safest bet you could possibly
make because given enough time he would
always change his opinion so you'd
always win the bet um so hucking points
are these hypothesized leftover effects
of black holes that are the only objects
that can perhaps survive the
conformal cyclic cosmological terminus
if you will
after trillions of years when nothing
left is is around black holes endure
black holes and actually magnetic fields
endure and they claim back in 2018 that
bicep was correct we did detect
primordial b modes but they weren't from
uh inflationary gravitational waves as
you know rogers uh finds that anathema
uh and uh but instead we're from the
aftershocks of these previous eons now
that allows me to pivot to my favorite
explanation as you know for the hubble
tension
which is
a resolution via primordial magnetic
fields i've done some videos on this
channel including one uh called the
hubble tension solved with magnetic
fields and we had a great uh
conversation with uh levon pagosian and
i've been in touch with his uh with his
colleague um carsten i always have
trouble pronouncing karsten's name and i
know he's listening because he he
hectors me when i make uh when i make
bad uh errors about hysteria carlston uh
judanzik
hopefully he's on anyway
primordial primordial magnetic fields
look like as good a solution as any
as i've seen and i don't i don't mean it
in a demeaning way i mean quite
seriously like the you know the idea
basically
the easiest way and there are no easy
ways but the easiest way to put all the
hubble tension is to change the
conditions of the universe uh before the
causing microwave background radiation
leaks out uh basically make it different
than the model in a way that generally
makes recombination happen earlier makes
the sound horizon smaller and my
understanding is primordial magnetic
fields would produce these in
homogeneities that would clump up the
universe faster earlier and cause that
kind of condition um and so
you know at a you know basic level it
could work now the devil's in the
details so you know i'll leave to you to
tell us how good the meatballs work yeah
well we're most interested in detecting
this via what's called the faraday
rotation of primordial polarization
fields would be revealed uh by the
existence of a deviation so-called
forbidden correlation sounds exciting
sounds sexy uh but it's really just the
uh the non-vanishing of so-called eb or
tb correlation functions and we're very
sensitive to that with instruments like
the simon's observatory upcoming and
current simon's array so that is one of
our primary goal this funny adam because
we proposed this as you know decades ago
starting with bicep uh to measure
inflationary b modes and that was
basically a one-trick pony for bicep at
least as i thought about it back in 2001
but since then we've really come upon
things that could invalidate uh such
closely held principles as lorenzen
variance symmetry
cosmic parity violation and other exotic
phenomena but along the way i don't know
philosophically if i've ever asked you
this but what is your you you do so much
you know and i i put in my uh first book
losing nobel prize whole you know
chapters uh 7 eight and nine are
dedicated to adam um
but um and chapter one of my newest book
into the impossible is adam literally uh
but i put in the thing that strikes me
about you is very good taste you've
not just
you know which podcast you come on but
you have very good taste that you've
cultivated
um are you still there
oh
i might have praised him too much
adam are you still there let's see if
we'll come back on um but i'll use this
opportunity to praise him while
hopefully he comes back on
um maybe his laptop bounced too much
but the um what i was going to say is
that as an as an astrophysicist or as a
scientist you need to kind of be very
selective about what you choose to
dedicate your finite amount of time
on earth to
so to speak and what adam's been
particularly good at is not only finding
the right problem but attacking its most
interesting
aspects with the greatest possible
tenacity that one could envision so here
is adam let's see if i can add him adam
can i add you are you there
yeah awesome sorry yeah i was praising
you so much your head swelled my head
exploded
see you you were talking about my taste
yeah i was saying i was saying it's one
thing to to be technically competent but
it's another thing to be doggedly in
pursuit of very subtle very confusing
and perplexing effects and consistently
do that and i i have an anecdote in this
book about how you know sitting behind
you at some conference before we really
got to know each other i mean we met in
the 2000s and but we never really got to
know but i remember like just watching
you know like this guy already has a
nobel prize he works his ass off and
he's got incredible heart uh hard
problems that he has incredible taste to
choose which part of your valuable time
to dedicate to how did you cultivate
that was that from bob was that from
just innately is that is that how you're
wired or how would you communicate to my
students i guess i would say all of my
mentors all of my you know teachers uh
have always seemed to have that that
good taste and always talked about you
know what would be really important to
do or what's really interesting um and
uh and i think you know in many ways
cosmology is that kind of pursuit
overall i mean it's a very reductionist
science uh we have very few very big
questions and you know the
the key to cosmology is sort of keeping
focused on the big picture you know the
big questions while you know you go off
on a deep dive on the details of of some
object or some measurement uh but never
really falling in love with the object
or the measurement getting back to the
big picture you know reminding yourself
you know these are tools to answer a
question uh it's not about the tools
themselves and so you know i feel like i
always learned that from my mentors yeah
wonderful um so maya is asking again
she's a theoretical physicist and
brilliant one at that she's asking can
you comment on wendy friedman's tip of
the red giant branch measurements of the
hubble constant yeah
what degeneracies does that break and
which ones does it still suffer from
right so um the the tip of the red giant
branch is a filter standard candle than
cepheus it's a kind of a newer tool that
people are using um and they have a much
smaller sample because you can't uh
reach out as far with those uh however
oh in there are about eight galaxies
where we can observe distances with both
the red giant branch and cepheid
variables and this is in our paper uh
where we have the measurements of the
same places they agree extremely well um
and so to me both techniques look good
uh but then as we increase our sample uh
our precision goes up um
although the results are consistent with
tip of the red giant branch they're more
significant um in terms of the
inconsistency with
the cosmic microwave background
very good uh andy oates long-term uh fan
of the show and friend of the show asked
would we get more precise measurements
of the hubble constant by placing
multiple telescopes at different
lagrange points so he's not satisfied
with l2 could we do anything i mean
hubble is not in a little garage point
hubble's like in our backyard
could you get anything from stereoscopic
or is that like gaia's purview so to
speak well i mean yeah
in principle if you could put two uh
identical observatories very very far
apart uh you can measure parallax uh
you know immediately um and that would
be really cool to do but you know to
improve over what we get from the earth
as the earth goes around the sun you
know we get two astronomical units of
diameter and so you basically have to
park one of those things over by you
know neptune or something uh to really
you know make headway so uh i would say
lagrange points don't really help in
that regard right well we've had
proposals from uh edward whitten
recently to send spacecraft out
to look for planet nine and uh that
would take about 100 years and measure a
time difference of less than a
microsecond for our great great
grandchildren to do so maybe it's not so
outlandish throw on a couple of
telescopes on that bad boy and get it
out to uh way beyond lagrange points
let's see uh another uh gentleman who
has a name that i also considered for my
my firstborn his name is zero skull
first of all he says i'm a fanboy of
adam murray all right fine
well you know i have to give him his due
i have to be you know respectful down
because i did beat him once in a very
prestigious competition uh where i came
in first and in a selection of potential
nobel prize winners in 2005 and you know
adam proved me wrong i suppose but but
anyway uh so yes i am a fanboy zero
skull but uh but your second question is
quite interesting you're talking about
um you know the gravitational effects
and i taught my students this uh
recently adam uh gravitational
measurements time delay measurements of
the hubble constant are those gonna ever
yield anything of interest or where do
we stand with that first of all could
you describe the physics look into your
you know crystal ball of gravitational
lensing and
explain a little bit about time delays
maybe um and then where could they
possibly go how competitive are they if
at all
yeah um so this is a technique where you
look at uh a very far away background
object i'm going to say maybe it's a
quasar or a galaxy and there's some
intervening galaxy or cluster or
something
that acts as a lens and so it bends the
light gravitationally and so you may get
multiple paths of light that are on
their way
uh
to some angle that would not come back
to you except the bending uh due to the
gravity uh brings the light back to you
so you might see multiple images
and you recognize that those multiple
images are traveling different paths
with different lengths so if you have
good telescopes and those objects vary
in some way you can measure the time
delay between those paths and
if you solve the whole problem then you
could ultimately get distances and
ratios of distances and the hubble
constant
the trick or the challenge in many cases
is knowing what that lens looks like how
mass is distributed in that lens whether
it's a galaxy or a cluster we know it
has a lot of dark matter but we don't
always know exactly how that matter is
distributed and so this is what i have
to say in in my field we call model
dependent um you know the answer often
depends on the model that you have for
how the matter is distributed um so you
know to my way of looking at it it's a
little less direct
uh a little less empirical
and it has this this model uncertainty
and so people have debated for a while
now what the right form of that uh the
mass distribution is um and so
uh there's one group uh the holy cow
team kind of a cool active one who said
if you use the most conventional mass
models
what are called power law or navarro
frank and white
uh models then they get a hubble
constant of 73 plus or minus two very
similar uh if they don't use those or
they open up that mass model uncertainty
then they could get anything from in the
mid 60s to the to the mid 70s so the
answer they get is fairly degenerate
with knowledge of this mass model and so
i think they continue to work on
improving knowledge of the the mass
models um and so i think this pertains
either to clusters or to individual
galaxies ah fascinating um thanks for
that adam so a reminder for those that
are just tuning in now we're getting
close to about 200 people watching on
all different platforms no pressure adam
so we're talking with uh professor adam
reece professor at johns hopkins and uh
also chapter one is uh is his biggest
accolade i think is is that he's chapter
one in my second book uh which is called
into the impossible think like a nobel
prize winner if you like interviews like
this please do subscribe but also leave
a thumbs up on the uh on the little icon
there so i can get uh folks uh like adam
and and
hottest cutting edge stuff we had chef
dolman on last week talking about the
exciting new results imaging the black
hole at the center of our galaxy after
the titanic observations of m87 uh they
followed up with event horizon uh what
what's most interesting to you outside
of what you're doing like what do you
what do you do in your spare time uh you
know what what do you read in the
non-fiction world of spare time besides
my books of course
in what am i interested in like for
example in science yes and science
you know i mean certainly it's not
something that i work on but the quest
to look for life around other planets is
terribly interesting um so you know the
whole field of exoplanets and um looking
at their atmospheres and trying to see
if there's bio signatures is
uh something that i i certainly follow
the that kind of work that my colleagues
do
uh so question also kind of uh you know
um what do they call those human
interest you know get to know the
noblest uh behind you are several books
i'm sure most of those are are copies
multiple copies of mine that'll help put
my kids through uh graduate school
people want to know what else do you
read what's on that bookshelf that
impressive looking bookshelf over here i
read a lot of history um i'm quite i i
minored in in history uh at mit which i
don't know if that counts but maybe
and
i've always been very interested in
history and i'm in a uh a book club on
in history so uh anyway i read a lot of
history books uh i think you learn a lot
about the president and future by
reading history i don't think things
change all that much and so uh if you
wonder how things will turn out read
history
and you are a historian of the cosmos
right you're looking at these sort of
ancient photons looking out in your
telescope uh so now i want you to look
in the future so look into your crystal
ball
and tell me a little bit about uh where
this field could be going you're saying
the bounds are sort of saturating from
hubble uh is it that we need more
theoretical understanding uh how much of
the of the error bar comes from
systematics in the theory of type 1as
right so so i'll back up a little bit
and say uh we went through a period in
the early 2000s the 2000 ox uh where
everything fit very well um in fact you
know we said you know cosmology was a
real consensus and that was great um and
in fact many of us feel like we should
quit then because you know there were
good feelings and and everything was
excellent however unfortunately we kept
pursuing uh more precise measurements
over the entire field uh you know planck
cmb observations bicep uh hubble
constant measurements i've been talking
about weak lensing measurements and maps
all kinds of techniques and as often
happens the better the measurements get
the the tighter the model is tested uh
we start to see tensions crop up in not
just the hubble constant but for example
uh another quantity known as sigma eight
which is uh a measure how clumpy the
universe is now uh and again sort of
like we see with the hubble constant uh
all of the
measurements locally in the late
universe don't know how clumpy the
universe is shows it to be much smoother
than you would predict based on the
cosmic microwave background state of
affairs and the cosmological model so
that's you know that's become kind of a
second major tension um and so looking
into my crystal ball you know we will
continue to improve measurements um and
uh maybe more tensions will come up
maybe really smart people will be able
to explain how these relate to each
other maybe we'll learn how to make
measurements better and that that will
be an important part of the story um so
you know it's it's hard to look too far
into the future but
i would say there's going to be better
cosmic microwave background observations
we're going to look for
uh signals of what i would call or what
people call pre-recombination new
physics which could show up in the the
fine structure of the cosmic ray
background power spectrum um we're going
to get observations uh from of
gravitational waves from ligo and more
advanced versions of ligo
that are going to give us an independent
way to measure distances and the hubble
constant they're going to be better a
weak lensing experiments from new
observatories like reuben uh and the
roman satellite is going to launch and
euclid is going to launch
so there's a lot of data coming into i
expect you know we will learn some new
things
yeah now on that topic uh chad grosskopf
a member of the channel one of my valued
members of the into the impossible
family he asked can we use black holes
expansion within a galaxy as a measure
of uh to help with the cobble tension i
think i'm going to change it around and
say can ligo or future incarnations can
they use so-called standard sirens or
will that never be as compel i mean
you're measuring things at the 1.3
percent you know uh precision level that
it's also accurate at that level um so
yeah can they ever do anything or is it
just going to be like okay they're
within five or ten percent of what's
right
you know i'm i'm optimistic i think you
know they're going to collect their
first i don't know a dozen or so and
that that will give us some interesting
constraints on the hubble constant the
problem becomes when they try to reach a
comparable precision where we are um it
turns out it's quite difficult to
calibrate their detector um to actually
figure out you know uh
how much strain which is the quantity
that they actually measure uh they
actually see and my understanding is
that there are even quantum effects that
become important in trying to calibrate
it finally and so you know i think they
will have to develop new techniques to
calibrate better look i mean we're in
some ways a hundred years ahead of them
you know thanks to henrietta levitt um
but uh you know they'll catch up they'll
make progress i don't know
you know how long it'll take to reach
the precision we're at but i think they
will be able to weigh in on this problem
in an interesting way you know hopefully
in another five years or so mm-hmm
you kind of answered this from
jeremiah's asking what's most excited
about in cosmology you also you know you
covered life extra terrestrial life etc
do you think by the way adam do you
think there's any
you know kind of um priors that one
could put upon uh the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence by the
non-observation or no evidence for it
and i asked that because i've had on a
lot of people including uh winner of the
pulitzer prize richard powers who's a
wonderful writer he wrote a book about
astrobiology which i think you'd love
called bewilderment it's a fictional
story about a father and son and dealing
with death and then all sorts of cool
things but also dealing with life in
other planets and i said to him i
you know i almost feel like i don't
think it's zero percent but i think it's
so incredibly rare that are such an
incredibly low probability that life
exists in the universe because i don't
feel there's any evidence within our own
solar system despite the millions of
years of billions of years of exchange
between planets and i usually have my
meteorite collection nearby but anyway
it goes by the dirty sounding name of
panspermia which isn't dirty don't worry
we won't get canceled but but the fact
that we have failed to observe life
on mars and and any other
sites in our own solar system at least
that has to put some bayesian limits on
the facility of the universe anyway what
do you think do you feel like it's just
there's so much space that literally
that there has to be life
i mean you know i i think uh my view is
the the common one held in our field
which is um you know
uh
there's a near infinite if not infinite
universe out there and so no matter how
rare you make life it's gonna be out
there
and so that's you know to first order my
general thinking i'm sure it is
incredibly rare um it's just you know we
have so many incredible
uh rolls of the dice i guess you would
say that it's bound to happen now what's
interesting for us is if it's sort of
detectable within our much more local
sphere and i think that is the big
question that you know fair
nobody really does know the answer to
that one um and so we will look for
example with the james webb space
telescope there's a number of programs
that will begin to study the atmospheres
of planets around other stars and uh
hopefully will teach us um about the
presence of that life
speaking of life uh kenneth m is asking
uh
if uh the government has contacted great
scientists like you or me uh to help in
the investigative process uh i am
tangentially involved with your alma
mater's uh famous uh search now called
the galileo project named after my
favorite hero in astronomy galileo
galilei run by avi lowe back at your
alma mater uh i want to ask you um i
mean i haven't been contacted i'm not
being cagey i'm just no i'm just kidding
i'm blanking i have something in my
actually i'd be more interested in the
former but the latter either yeah either
way
neither
uh so
now do you think this is a subject that
deserves
you know the funding the attention in
congress
a lot of my my viewers do like to
speculate about this and like to hear
from honest to goodness scientists such
as yourself that are working at the
highest levels um you know is this
something that a serious scientist
should pursue you know avi gets a lot of
kind of pushback he's been a guest on
the show many times right um what do you
think about this is it is it because of
the prosthetic forehead problem that
it's kind of ridiculed and not seen as a
great vector to get tenure or do you
feel like maybe you should spend one
percent of your you know time on it or
something so so when i went to graduate
school i almost worked on seti i thought
about doing it and actually my sister my
older sister said you know i don't i
don't really see how you're going to
graduate and get a phd if you don't
detect anything uh and uh i followed her
advice uh however i must say
i do think that we should be working on
this we should be spending significant
funding on it it's the ultimate hail
mary of all research i cannot think of
any discovery that would be more
profound uh that would be more impactful
in our the way we look at
the universe to the way we look at each
other
than the discovery of life around other
planets um you know i i have kind of
fantasy hope that it would have this
kind of
existential impact on people you know
maybe it's a being you know overly
optimistic but that it would cause
people to sort of reset their
perspectives in helpful ways so
on many different levels i think uh it's
you know it's the greatest quest of all
yeah i i certainly agree and that's look
it's two people and we have no you know
fiduciary interest in this field
and yet um and yeah we both find it
interesting i do you know with love and
respect i push back because i actually
don't think it would be i think it would
be big news for a news cycle um i see i
remember back in 1996 when you and i
were grad students not far apart from
one another um i was at brown
where i'm going back and uh you were up
at
harvard and um i remember there was a
there was a huge discovery in fact it
made uh the the uh the white house lawn
with bill clinton
the mars rock found in antarctica and
you know what adam that's never been
disconfirmed that that is still under
active study 30 years hence and there's
no telling where that without so
actually i do get as i often get i often
get you know oh you're part of bicep
like you guys won the nobel prize right
in other words like the newspaper on the
front page and i've told dennis oberby
this and other people you know the story
goes on page one the discovery claim
as it did with bicep as it did with your
supernova measurements and but if
there's a retraction it's on b17 of the
saturday edition that nobody so nobody
knows that i mean very few people even
in astronomy know that bicep is
disconfirmed i mean a lot of people do
but some people come up to me in
astronomy and say wow that's amazing um
so i'm going to ask you like what what
you know to what degree should science
sensationalism and you know i was joking
i read about your discovery in the new
york post you know
and just as they say just because it's
in the new york post doesn't mean it's
wrong uh but you know what extent should
scientists be responsible for their you
know stray findings and things that go
straight should we keep a budget you
know in in hand for retractions
as well as press conferences
uh
i think retractions are important i
understand that um you know people don't
cite errata as much as they cite regular
papers and they generally put them uh
in the newspaper and i know quite a
number of papers specific ones which
have made a big claim and then you know
later on either retracted or through
even the refereeing the peer review
process changed quite dramatically um
you know unfortunately just the nature
of humans is to
you know be excited to hear something
really really interesting and then to
find it much less interesting if it was
you know retracted but you know points
overall is pretty good i don't think
we're led astray by these things very
long um you know it might be that you
know people on the street don't know uh
something was retracted but people in
the field do know uh you know it doesn't
it doesn't uh deter us for too long yeah
very good well adam if you have a few
more minutes i have a couple more
questions from the audience if that's
okay
sure okay so uh maya's asking another
phenomenal question god my i hope we
meet someday you're just full of ideas
and questions she's now asking about um
about local dynamics that could
masquerade as a cosmological constant
and i want to pivot off that question
and maybe uh turn it around a little bit
for years there was interest in mind
modified newtonian dynamics as a
solution for dark matter and i'm
wondering inspired by her question
are there any analogs of bond but for
dark energy other explanations if you
will that could explain via
modifications of gravity newtonian or
otherwise that could explain and account
for
you know uh the observations that you
and your colleagues have been making
right so so to be clear when we talk
about any of the things we talk about
the accelerating expansion the hubble
tension everything um it's all based on
assuming einstein's general relativity
works and that we can use the universe
as a laboratory following the rules of
general relativity and so you know we
would say well general relativity isn't
right all bets are off on these
measurements and in the interpretations
uh and so uh
you know we're always open to a new idea
for what gravity could be now before i
get flooded with tons of messages and
and
papers or whatnot the it is very
difficult people have always struggled
to come up with an alternative to
general relativity that actually is not
ruled out inside the solar system or on
earth or many other things and you know
this is the difference between you know
scientists and in some cases you know
armchair scientists is they have an idea
that's great but you got to check it
first and see if it's already ruled out
uh and as i said nearly all of them are
um and so uh you know the gauntlet
really thrown down by the universe in
terms of coming up with an alternative
however you know having said that we
don't have a quantized theory of gravity
we don't know how to unite general
relativity with quantum theory the you
know physics of large and small so there
is reason to believe that there is still
more to understand about gravity uh and
so uh i think it's a very active area of
research yeah
so uh one last question from the
audience before we break and it has to
do with with sacred cows um and i guess
the question i could be uh summarizing
it um maybe with some discretion on my
part um if
if the question is by craig dean is dark
energy a sacred cow in other words
hasn't reached the level of originally
when you put this out in the 90s you and
your colleagues it was you were
it was it was considered exactly the
opposite we didn't we didn't expect it
we thought einstein was correct the last
word took tremendous courage for you and
your colleagues
but now it's become the standard in fact
barbara ryden's wonderful book that i
use is called calls it this the
benchmark model and it's uh and it's and
it's phenomenal so i wonder though you
know is it is it possible that something
could be almost like too successful in
other words if you say that this is yeah
go ahead right or that we maybe or that
we cling to it in some way that we say
well there's got to be dark energy so
i'm not open to other possibilities you
know my experience is scientists are
much more open than uh people in many
other fields you know we grew up with
this idea that we have models that we're
testing and falsifying and we've seen
through the history of science this is a
very successful process so um it's okay
if we falsify dark energy or dark matter
or anything um but uh we still have to
explain the evidence that led us to
believe in them so you know in the case
of my colleagues and i uh what we
discovered was not so much dark energy
as we discovered that the expansion of
the universe is speeding up that it's
accelerating if there's another way to
explain that without dark energy you
know modification to gravity or
something i think we'd be very open to
that i certainly know i would be um and
i just i'm very confident in the science
method that you know if the data is
better for an alternative hypothesis
than the ones that we have then that
will win out it always has
so when we talked a couple years ago in
the interview that made the opening
chapter of my second book into the
impossible we talked about something
that i call the academic hunger games
which is that you have all these hurdles
to get up to and get through and then
finally you might get a
faculty job and if you get a faculty job
you might get tenure and to get tenure
you might win some prizes and get
citations and so forth and i asked you
do you ever feel like the game is broken
and you said yes i think it's not a
great scheme i'm lucky that i did not
feel compelled by that scheme and that's
something that's parenthetically always
impressed me about you you've never been
driven like the nobel prize for you is
just it was a great thing obviously but
it wasn't like what you set off to do
since you were a kid unlike some people
president company uh but
but my uh my my my question now involves
something that brian schmidt and your
fellow laureate and i talked about um
which is that he viewed with regret and
he was a post-doc if i'm not mistaken
while you were a student and you guys
were incredibly tightly uh you know
working close together and you had these
competitors on the supernova cosmology
project led by saul paramounter who has
yet to reply to an email let alone come
on the show but hopefully he will
someday um but saul you know and his
group you know saul's a very mild
mannered appearing person but but from
what i heard from alex philopenko and
from and from brian was that uh they
regretted most kind of the what what
brian called toxicity that that there
was kind of a message communicated to
young people like you um that you know
science is this incredibly cutthroat as
i say the academic hunger games
prevailed even within a collaboration
how did you overcome it and um you gotta
experience like you know children of
divorce are more likely to get divorced
uh i'm told uh but uh but you know how
did you overcome it and and what advice
do you give to mentors and other people
like me and my audience
to kind of you know show the right side
of science as as you've been doing so
yeah
you know that's a good question it's a
big question um you know i'm going to
kind of reframe this as um you know the
the role of competitiveness that shows
up in science and is it healthy is it
unhealthy uh you know lots of it is
unhealthy but on the other hand just as
i described i mean science is always
this ultimate competition between ideas
uh between data uh you know in the case
of these two teams making this discovery
it was important to people to see two
teams uh you know uh reaching similar
conclusions um so you know i would say
that uh you know it has positives and
negatives uh but you know you have to
ultimately keep it in check because you
know who are we competing with the
universe i mean you know the ultimate
competition here is you know the
universe sort of guard secrets doesn't
make things obvious as far as we can
tell and you know we're competing to try
to figure out those things and you know
the best science ultimately builds on
other science so you know i look at my
quote competitors papers to learn things
and to learn you know what should i do
better what should i do differently what
did they find from this experiment so
you know i think it just takes
uh scientists recognizing hey the
competition is out there it's in the
universe you know the challenges are out
there um yeah i mean it's it you know we
may have a little bit of local
competition to see you know do we agree
do we disagree but you know you don't
want to lose perspective uh otherwise
you know the science will lose you will
lose and you'll be very unhappy
well adam i wanna thank you so much for
coming on the show um anything you wanna
mention or something coming up for you
uh looking forward to getting back to
conferences and so forth this summer
sure and i'm looking forward to uh the
james webb space telescope uh everybody
should look forward to july
is when i expect we will see first
images that's phenomenal yes we've uh
had a couple of guests on hakimo la shea
and others on the show and
talked about that and then definitely
will have more results and and uh great
guests coming on so thank you so much i
had uh john mather on and got to get him
back on as well because uh it's it's
great to have uh scientists that do
outreach and communicate with the public
and that's what i try to do on this
channel i hope you'll all subscribe and
and follow adam and uh and and myself
and and look forward to many many cool
episodes coming up jared lewis is coming
on the podcast and aegis who's got an
interesting model called
called the bouncing cosmological model
kind of competitor to inflation she's a
wonderful guest recorded with her
recently and adam uh thank you so much
short notice uh it's late in the night
getting out there where you are i do
hope we can uh meet again in person it's
been too long yeah
sounds good thank you my friend bye bye